Gwen Stacy cheated on me with Green
Goblin and that's actually a thing get
back here you big green [ __ ] ah hard to
dodge cuz they like they follow you yes
you know ah
he has heat-seeking fireballs this is a
little weird cuz you think they just
explode instantly the second he threw
them or like they would go towards him
something all god this is probably the
hardest chase in the game or maybe the
one of the later ones is I think the
last one is probably the hardest but
that one I do okay one okay so yeah this
is the ultimate version of Green Goblin
as a kid because I hadn't quite gotten
to that part of the comics yet to see
that this was ultimate Green Goblin I
always assumed that this was abomination
like the Hulk villain ah [ __ ]
like even though they say Osborne in the
cutscenes like I was like [ __ ] I would
six at the time when this game came out
seven so I wasn't exactly paying a ton
of attention to story stuff please stop
there you go alright jump go this way
thank you [ __ ] I grin into a tree okay
I like how sometimes does it take like
one or two strides and run like normal
instead of hopping what the [ __ ] is the
point of that other than to just give
like the players cheats
extra frames to catch up yes
come back alright I got you this time
you won't escape me now you big fella
it's a little weird that in the context
of the game Peter doesn't seem that
fazed by Osborn being here considering
he knows the Green Goblin this is like
his nemesis but he just kind of doesn't
give a [ __ ] really it's like I am just
another one of them random chuckle [ __ ]
I have to fight this is the part where
they try to screw you over by not giving
you a ton of things what's going on two
more about like Webb's missing
I know how to get around that part about
that party it's this part coming up
that's annoying
get back here sobbing I kind of want
missions like this in spider-man ps4 I
don't know why I kind of missed chasing
people you don't do it anymore
all right I'm going to need at least
like two or three tries of it I can
already tell this one is such a pain and
I've already taken damage already feel
I'm gonna definitely get my ass kicked
whoa yeah
all right please go all right fire ball
one fireball - yeah thank you all right
cool get out seriously
ah [ __ ] no no no no no hurry go I have
to say the other person okay uh caution
be damned I just have to get you out of
there oh [ __ ]
you know I always kind of like it
whenever spider-man cusses because of
course he would you know one thing I
noticed about more recent spider-man
comics is that there's a sort of like
conceded effort to make him more of like
a do-gooder Boy Scout
like for example in issue 600 when Aunt
May gets married to uh you know Jay
jonah Jameson dad you know he gets like
that was the first time Mary Jane had
come back after one more day so it was
weird seeing her again and then Peter
started having like a freak out and then
got super drunk at the party and then
slept with his roommate Michelle and
then that just caused like awkward
tension between the characters and they
also had to figure out exactly where he
was gonna meet Mary Jane the next day
because she told him to go hey he got
hit by a part of us cuz she told him
that you need they needed to meet
together the next day and he couldn't
remember cuz he was so wasted and then
later a different writer than Dan Slott
who wrote that story decided to go back
and add this stupid conversation saying
that someone had switched out his drinks
at the party because he was like he only
had like two two beers and then they're
like yeah we'll change it so that he
just raced out all night and was just
making it up that he was super drunk and
it was like come on that set more
braking and dumb just let him do bad
things occasional oh where you go I hate
it when the check he's ever done this
time something even worse happens about
two seconds
[Music]
and I also like when Spiderman cusses
not because like I like him being edgy
in dark but I think it's more human for
him to do and if it never feels out of
place when I see him do it like it's out
of place to see Captain America cos
that's the thing I don't like buts
better managed he's just a normal guy he
was cut and whenever he does it it seems
fine but then more recent writers have
tried to kind of [ __ ] by him and make
it so he doesn't do that sort of thing
and he doesn't get drunk and it's like
like I'm super wildly opposed to
drinking alcohol in real life but I'm
fine with the character doing it because
it just seems more like a thing that
people do not everyone has to be like
unrealistically moral about everything
oh I was going to talk about Green
Goblin in this part hey remember that
time that Gwen Stacy and Green Goblin
had kids together yeah okay
it's also funny when Spiderman starts
like speaking in like Yiddish [ __ ]
Ben this is writing three Easter strong
in like Jewish slang terms all right
please stop throwing things at me god
these are so hard to avoid you no no no
oh that's it all right
well at least I hit a checkpoint right
and I'll get health back because it
started that would have helped all right
[ __ ] you we're on even terms now Norman
[Music]
come on I was still was like [ __ ]
talking and then I got hit talk [ __ ] get
hit okay your ass is the same color as
grant and I will do with it as as such
it will bemoan that a word know mode
whatever talking and flying video game
is hard and keeping the deep enough one
schedule is apparently harder [ __ ] stop
you're making me look bad so yeah one
time Glenn and odds weren't had a bunch
of kids and that was a really like
interesting concept and I wish they
hadn't abandoned it almost immediately
like and then there was also like the
thing where Stravinsky had suggested
originally that it would be a Peters kid
that he had with Glenn and they had like
the weird progeria thing but then the
editorial staff was like nah you can't
do that leave that out and then he
changed it so that was Osborne's kid and
it seems like odd foreign maybe warrants
actually ever acknowledged it and it was
in that American Sun book which I didn't
review oh come on
okay alright
[Music]
haha dodge them you've got a jump right
when they get close alright this is um
I'm getting it I'm getting in the zone
you don't got [ __ ] come on throw another
one you suck at this ah hey people ask
me what I think of that a whole
storyline with the Goblin kids and I
think it's a thing it's actually kind of
neat it's a little out of character for
Glenn dual-flush Norman Osborn and she
was like the night scene when she died
in his life okay stop right
ah I have now officially run out away I
agree what is this again all right here
we go phase two jumping up and down I
put this section of the box right is
okay okay all right chill out a little
what's five fingers damn face look
brighter dream than he did a few seconds
ago
am I crazy okay
ah that sucks
ah I got a feel laughs good morning come
on hop on over there you go ruin some
more of this IKEA furniture you rub [ __ ]
I just it was a big one the big jump do
it
oh he's just making this more difficult
there we go I like how I hopped off the
death to hit him harder in the face
I'm just going to take a second take a
breather do your thing okay fellas short
but nice break I got in a corner so
goblin kids is a cool concept but they
should have done more with it instead of
like getting ashamed of it and then
pretending it Genesis almost immediately
it's another thing like every time you
introduce a concept with spider-man it
either gets like sometimes there's cool
ones that were it's like yeah I'd see
where that goes and then it gets
abandoned like I liked it when he was a
teacher they're all it's all a lot of
these situations is from J michael
Straczynski
I liked it when he was a teacher but
they kind of like gave up on that pretty
quick I liked it when they tried the
Goblin kids thing because that was like
a fun like plot twist oh my god
revelation it's all shutting down all
right let's see if I can get him this
time
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah that sucked
he did a fatality move on me
oh no oh wait back here yeah I didn't
know that this was uh I know that that
would happen
all right I appreciate that like my
vision is obscured by the clumps that
he's about to throw the fireballs I
can't see what the hell is happening
with those last six hits connecting or
was I just wasting my time
I think this version of Green Goblin is
a lot less fun because he doesn't say
anything he just kind of a mindless
monster and doesn't really have a whole
lot going on and the motivation is kind
all over the place his powers are dumb I
think the death of spider-man well-well
told for what it is like I it's very
obvious that Brian Michael Bendis was
again like just kind of making it up as
he went along
there's a lot of a lot of contrivance to
set up that quad and it just kind of
came out of nowhere like it felt
convenient you know like the rest of the
Avengers are too busy to help spider-man
okay so then he gets killed and then he
has superhero friends living with Aunt
May with him and then he just wakes up
the long one and that kind of hinges on
the entire fight then Human Torch give
Green Goblin a power boost
instead of Iceman kicking that fall down
alright never mind and then uh [ __ ] I am
I'm not doing well I'm not doing well at
all it just give me it just see me some
rest okay yeah all right now to snack
every day
ah okay take it easy
[Music]
dammit
okay cutscene time gonna get my ass
kicked
we saw this already let's just let's
just get skip to the part where I die oh
I got caught no get a desk that's good
kitty pryde ever has that problem when
she looks like lifting objects and
doesn't know how to get out okay I have
a very slim chance of doing this okay
all right out I'm out I'm out goodbye
please give me a break
let's be friends
hey do you think Kevin Spacey would make
a good dog off it's got like the right
body type for it you can play like a
smart / crazy characters regal I don't
know just thought I've seen Alfred
Molina lately and you know what he's
like
closer and body type and voice wise -
doc ock now than he was in 2004 okay got
a chance okay I'm out goodbye when we're
fireball and I'm my ass I keep saying my
ass is dry I guess that's like a
catchphrase now know what else is a
catchphrase
I am the Von's how much water do I need
to keep you okay ha ha bye yeah all
right you got magic pixels - uh-huh
[ __ ] this is close no all right I think
I've done it
[ __ ] you I did it
ma'am so Drake what a good note to end
on
I want a genetic suppressor collar on
Osborne three minutes ago get this area
sealed off inside of ten seconds or I'll
fire the first one of us you was fury
mmm good job here could you have made a
bigger mess no and believe me I tried
you've got some mouth on you
Wow do you think he'd be a teeny bit
nicer considering an age did your job
for you
please how the web without side of the
panel but then he went under the panel
like the way the cutscene nevermind
anyway yeah that's cool that was just
kind of filler and was there for an
extra box like that doesn't have
anything to do with what's going on with
venom and I really feel like there was
planned for a sequel to this because
they kept doing stuff like that and then
never went anywhere with it so yeah
death of spider-man I don't like it very
much
but it might just be because I don't
like the idea of Peter Parker getting
killed like a punt on his front lawn see
if I were to do it I would have him get
like just [ __ ] stomped by like sixty
villains at once like I I know would be
hard to have that many in the book but
you could do it he has a big enough
rogues gallery get everyone out of
retirement or unfilled or whatever and
then you just have them at all time you
have them all attack at once and then
make sure the situation because it's
kind of like I feel like you could just
argue well why don't the Avengers go
save them if it happens quickly enough
they really won't be able to have time
to react and there's a been a couple of
situations where something like that is
almost happened like in a Marvel night
spider-man when Green Goblin breaks at a
Rikers Island he has like the sinister
six or a form of it kind of like
impromptu gather together to kick
spider-man's ass and the only reason you
get that of that is because eventually
the Avengers show up to pull them out of
there so I mean a really is really just
instead of writing a really lame reusing
for the Avengers to not be there because
they're all fighting communists
spider-man or whatever his Ultimate
Comics or squalus come have it so that
like he just gets kind of like like
sneak attacked by like 20 of his
villains at once what's my goal what are
my goals but that's the question people
on asking of what gah combat sir oh [ __ ]
okay well I know where a couple those
are let's go yeah I guess a despawned
want to do them well there'll be more on
that you know something else I think is
weird is that Manhattan Island is shaped
differently in real life than it is in
like all video games like they just cut
off the back chunk of it like you're
here let me show you it doesn't just
stop like that there's like a whole
other chunk off in this area that they
always kind of leave out like they have
it or no no not that and it's over on
this side it connects with a whole other
chunk of City on the other side of you
know what is it the opposite side of the
Statue of Liberty and on the other side
of the island it just goes off into what
I think is I think it's like Brooklyn no
no Brooklyn's across the bridge and the
geography of it is a little confusing if
you've never been there because the maps
in all of video games and TV seem to
just kind of like neglect half of the
island and also like three or four of
the surrounding island
like no one ever talks about like was a
Governors Island I think is right next
to it and that one's like I don't know
maybe at least like 10% of the same size
as the main island oh there's a comment
orosco do that one or uh you never see
like Staten Island often all right I
guess next time we'll start up with this
this year combat tour but because we're
running a little over our time and I
think I might have to go take a break
right now to go record something with
David go check that out on his channel
I'll link it right here once it comes
out but knowing him he'll be really slow
about editing it so you know I might
forget see you next time remember when
in May was supposed to have her own
movie